let's see if it's working this turns us
straight
so today we are going to be taking these
Miracle Berries which apparently make
sweet things taste sweeter and sour
things taste sweet ah
whoa
oh that was weird oh that was weird this
is I'm feeling it now
oh my God
oh yeah oh yeah oh that's like a cupcake
it tastes normal to me I'm broken yeah
[Music]
okay I can taste the difference there
that's because I eat so much kimchi that
tastes like there's like they've dumped
a cup of sugar in it I just keep wanting
to like sword fight with you I know okay
very much like the film
[Music]
just like pepperoni oh I don't like that
it tastes like meat cake you can see the
mono right now on Netflix go watch it
and we hope you love it as we do